Oh welcome to this video playing the
Blitz Ryder here with black and let's
see if I can stop my stone like for
reading should FC I can go here actually
some very comparable to two other lines
sorry so what to do here yeah maybe okay
we should be six this night f4 where
should I play Knight f6 aw isn't this
isn't this a good place hmm now can
maybe okay this is Bishop f4 coming back
then sorry I really have some problems
with my ycm let's see
I Bishop f4 is a bit but annoying if
this is coming
hmm okay I probably have to do this it
should be seven a drone castles to to
protect my queen side and then go go
from here um should I play Knight f6 I
don't know f5 is a move that also comes
into consideration maybe 95 then let's
let's play it anyway 95 not sure how bad
it really is maybe I can take your form
I haven't calculated this really hoping
that it's not not any good okay push yer
purty 635 or okay if we look at the
captcha Fe form Bishop c7 yeah that's a
very very weakened structure ah ok then
then the whole thing wasn't a good idea
okay oh this I overlooked great gets
better and better
hmm
we are not sure how bad it really is to
be honest I can maybe take care three
takes my dev six it's this so bad I
don't really see it at the moment it
does not get to the critical squares
really rook b6 Bishop c6 is even
questionable if the rookies fulfilling
any useful role on b6 I might even try
that now this is OK from like okay Oh
put them ATM Knight b6 mate
not very nice look you want maybe
I can play look of seven to cover the
bishop but it's a very very an ammonia
spizz ition ok now it looks very
critical but the question is can he can
he really increase him can he can he
really increase the pressure yeah how do
I get out of this I can go to we ate i
can go to e7 actually to is 7 95 95 King
c6
g7 is this enough yeah at least it
should should have some problems frame
to keep some harmony Bishop d16y8 and
there are some self pins working
hmm not not clear to me check maybe here
96 is mostly a self-penned so okay it's
not going for it it goes here now maybe
maybe activator okay with ether and
maybe in the mix but not now and thou
bishop somewhere bishop here maybe
taking the night ok so the night is not
a big problem anymore it's not
threatening to do something terrible
directly maybe I can somehow get in f4
under under good circumstances of course
here maybe it cannot take Bishop h3s
winning to move the night I will move
the night but ok let's do this anyway
I'm money once or III maybe III it's not
a great idea and maybe just take it now
should h3
that's not great you can take you for
Allah can take your form check why am I
thinking for so long I chart terribly
unpractical him just when I get a
position where I can hardly lose any
more I'm letting the clock runs out
doing everything I can to to screw this
up
you can always be annoying with the
night of course
yeah they came in it's it's it's really
not really important it's just a matter
of a time loss this position even after
giving back the exchanges of course just
a draw
check hmm yeah it's it's just opposite
colored bishops with no winning chances
for wide whatsoever
check check black Chaffetz on time yeah
of course a totally totally dead
position but okay we play this
anachronistic time control what can you
do but it's my old phone I mean I'm just
clearly better here and not winning he
had some substantial compensation but it
fizzled out and there aren't here black
yes just just I just I should just win
here with good technical plane but I
just decided to let the clock run down
with moves like f4 it wasn't even a good
move I can play with these six or
whatever just anything rookie to just
keep the position as it is I don't know
I simply take all the wrong decisions at
the moment and after that I'm I'm just
losing the threat with the time here of
course no problem whatsoever you can
play whatever you want and losing is
basically impossible with our time of
course if its position by set says it's
impossible yeah okay it's a big slump
it's a big slump if you look at this and
it took you can look at the wrist theory
here I mean I'm hovering about 22 and
the last game 0 the loss loss loss rod
or a win loss loss loss I mean just and
I don't even have very good opposition
if you look at the opponent's ratings
it's hardly any title play and now who
okay well thanks for watching and
suffering together with me